bom dia cala boca
o bom dia foi de alegria no porquê da
tia eu acabei de acordar e hoje eu vou
mostrar como é que é um dia de show meu
onze horas da manhã agora mas isso
porque você acordou tarde porque galera
antes de vir para teresina para pegar o
vôo eu saio de sobral então saiu ontem
de sobral e ônibus em cheguei muito
cansado e já cheguei eu cheguei de manhã
em dormir acordei agora e daqui a pouco
tem que pegar um avião para o natal lá
vai ser o nosso show vocês vão
acompanhar tudo de pertinho então vão
para o porto e estamos no aeroporto
agora quero aqui fazer o check in para
depois quem quiser pegar um vôo para ir
pra frente à fortaleza
espero um pouco em fortaleza de
fortaleza finalmente arena de natal
agora vamos pegar um avião
aquele foi um propaganda gota gol me
paga por amor de deus nos preparamos
para decolagem e retorne o recurso de
sua bunda para a posição vertical
mantendo sua mesa fechada e trabalhada
assegure se que seu cinto de segurança
esteja revelado
pedimos agora sua atenção para a
demonstração dos procedimentos de
segurança freqüente em caso de uma
receberá você já tinha lembra com essa
integração exigência muito desigual
caíram automaticamente já tem barba e
cabelo curto não fugiu à na bancada
federal junto da chacina especial não é
chegar aqui em fortaleza
agora é só esperar que matou somente uma
hora e meia pra pegar o voo para
finalmente a onde a paz quando eu
cheguei no natal e agora vou manchar
essa
nessa semana a cne derrotas coisa queria
fazer agora é sul-americana que chuta
máquina e cair um bom uma coca e um
sanduíche mas é melhor não fazer que o
mastro acontecer eu ser preto que a
máquina que acertar mil reais só porque
está grudada
são puro preconceito com a simples nota
que está colado com 11 durex já estão
aqui esperando há duas horas se errou já
estava em do marrocos que até agora não
chegou e eu não sei mas já estou
começando a cheirar mal eu quero chegar
no hotel para tomar um bom banho e
cachimbo o despacho chuá chuá
agora chegou finalmente a gente vai pra
natal
é o que é que eu vou go
vamos nessa finalmente no pai natal
a gente vai chegar lá mas vamos à meia
noite e aí vou chegar à meia noite a
gente vai jantar tomar um banho e
descansar para amanhã pela manhã não
lembrar do sábado passado sábado logo
aquilo não foi legal
e aí a gente vai amanhã se preparara e
tal só depois dia 7 e de hoje fazer
ocioso para o avião na boca betinho
finalmente aqui dentro do avião agora
espera o momento para a partida
vamos orar a deus
informamos que as aeronaves será
abastecido de combustível há pouco o
primeiro galera até estamos aqui em
natal chegando agora são meia noite em
ponto a gente acabou de chegar à meia
noite e meia noite ao chegar ao posto de
parecer bem grande
é um negócio vai entrar não sei porque
tranqüila escada iphone que cheguei me
roubar lhe pega a mala de idiota que vem
de mala e todo mundo tem um bolsa para
não pegar a mala mas o imbecil é que 20
e que neymar
agora finalmente chegamos aqui estamos
em natal estamos meu quarto né cara
legal pra [ __ ] e tem uma vista parada
mostra aqui pra vocês e vamos dormir que
amanhã 6 têm trabalho é galera de banho
tomado o caminho lavado o xxiii e ganha
é você só eu e edson nunes
bom dia galera vamos levantar a galera
já amanheceu com muita chuva que natalie
galera amanheceu muita chuva que em
natal hoje o mar o que acontece agora a
gente vai tomar café é pra ficar bem
forte e ir para as televisões da
entrevista
vamos lá
sitebarra parecia buscar gente com a
televisão
eu vou me ligou e eu eu vou que vou eu
vou que go curte abraça lá no baile bom
e um nada andou lancinante oms chan foi
pra lá mas não tá bonita machado
os manos serigado rolando só diga quem
gostou camaro land chuva missa da gente
aí troy
galera vou sair daqui do sbt
daqui de natal estamos indo agora para
uma rede tv
a redetv de natal também cabe a nós
chegamos aqui na redetv de natal eo
bairro da serraria e da melhoria
dinheiro e me conectar para o baile funk
o tempo que rezar para um hotel sem
cabos aí eu não consigo mudar é bem
chato já que esse tipo de madrugada pra
dormir
futebol teatro alberto entende melhor o
tempo seja não é e quem não é embora nós
com isso fazer um pocket show só pra mim
galera acabou de acabar entrevista aqui
na rede tv
e agora a gente vai almoçar né acho que
agora a gente vai almoçar e depois eu
vou poder em falhar pra poder que o show
já é amanhã
oi
o eleitor oi agora é de bom tom é também
evitar tudo 500 e direito não para que
entre amanhã em barra 1 alan sua clube
jorge sabe da galera família noite de
natal
a grécia é e os mais jovens então eu
falar que eu sou o tal que ninguém sabe
pra eu não tenho ninguém tinha seu nome
a essa maldade olha olha laura flavia
fernandes flávia fernandes de araújo
tá bom pois você vai lá que tá lá
pode ir aonde eu vou botar o nome eu era
o que queria com o nome aqui e quando
chega lá só mostra identidade ele bota
pra dentro
a charanga
eu acho que não pareceu tão perto daí
foi eleito respirar
é bom que ântero é e quanto isso é falha
de marital pode pode
até então o frango no começo eu não pode
mesmo lhe então olha o seguinte olha que
disse aqui que é melhor treinar loja
pegar o ingresso então não ter uma
semana de fevereiro com um ipod hoje ele
deixou então nós vai deixar tudo na loja
é só chegar e falar que a menina que eu
era que mandou pagar ingresso e
reingresso e ninguém sai da brigada
militar do vale tudo e chorona não já
não estava um cheiro ruim desde a minha
chegada
a gente mas que humildade em pé e num
mundo só tem eu eu gostei
prometeu hoje procurar passar trazer de
volta agora sim chegamos no hotel e
abril ficou sozinha agora vai acontecer
aqui vocês verem está a praia vão estar
aqui o que é isso uma marchinha vai lá
vai lá vai lá vai lá aqui logo ao fundo
a gente pode ver o oceano índico que vai
dar no mar morto onde o mar vermelho se
encontra ea menstruação rola
agora finalmente um descanso agora aqui
galera galera que é uma hora que a gente
sempre faz é sempre que a gente faça um
trabalho alguma coisa a gente vem pra
piscina do hotel para dar uma relaxada e
hoje a gente passou o dia com rental e o
show já é amanhã a gente vem aqui
é o que falei doutor ariel mar galera
agora vou mostrar pra vocês como eu sou
especialista em nadar 100 metros rasos
entendeu 100 metros rasos copiada
é é agora estamos aqui numa américa do
sul
fecha
o toque de novo e mande a foto de novo
plantão
o dia hoje é o dia do show era só
exatamente galera é exatamente 11 6 aqui
em natal tem sessão às 4 horas de sessão
acho que as 6 horas
então a gente já tem que almoçar e
portia porque a gente testa os
instrumentos antes desta voz como é que
tá agora está tudo ok e agora no camarim
até a hora do show eu vou tomar um banho
agora vou tomar um banho e já vou ficar
pronto fechou a r time conte até agora
a beleza é galera tarde até agora
diana que arruda tinha porque sair num
mensalmente bem grande bem grandão então
a gente
por medida de segurança entrar por outro
local
hum
mãe eu sou aí ó nóis
i ó
sou eu sei que tenho
a galera do cinema noir não olha a minha
de 2010 a jovem
bom aqui ea gente para atender a fãs e
ganhou uma promoção do instagram
pagadora ver aqui eu comigo falando aqui
e já fui da compal que agora é só
esperar a hora de entrar
galera agora é hora de esperar a hora de
ser chamado e enquanto isso eu vou tirar
uma soneca
enganei vocês a gente não dorme há a
soma da típica acervo seja feita a
doação da área
o museu como o nosso de cada dia nos dai
hoje atendido não mexer com a irritação
a elevar o nome do pai
com um aparelho novo e um ano mais tr
também o único
quem mora lá e ela falou também do time
com uma rosa neto am
ai ai essa lei está mudando ela avalie
uma onda ainda defendia o título
elza
é tudo muito gostoso
ae além da derrota em seis jogos
é isso aí galera acabou a primeira
sessão agora aqui tem uns 300 ac tem
outro presente fora que vai pegar ea
gente vai descansar agora alguns
minutinhos subir aqui já são 17 e 9 acho
que é dito a gente vai descansar aqui
uns 15 minutos vai começar a entrar com
o estado as pessoas podem fazer a
segunda sessão é papai nininho e galera
tô aqui com vocês um pouco pensando aqui
né
obrigado a todo mundo vai assistir
quando vou fazer show foi do [ __ ]
o sim corações mais aqui ó do karatê
decidido
obrigado galera mesmo que tinha morto de
cansado é a automação água e voltar prá
2ª
é é a
o mesmo esquema eles querem vencer o
canal e
a consulta ao lote pode ser jorge mateus
joão pessoa raoni esse vai ser um
campeonato não é fácil encarar o jorge
mateus
você pode ser campeão porque cathels
essa honra e até o altar mas detalhe é
que o time estava muito fácil estava em
recesso de começo para fazer no final
era para você coloca uma casa em chicago
o que você vai dizer que você estava se
manifesta se parece não parece está bom
até um negócio assim não chega a sinop
aponta ótima então aqui eu é os 15 anos
quem toca um pouco a pele
o souza que chefiou a pessoa tá bom tá
bom eu já gostava é que a mãe é um
pouquinho mais na palavra só um
pouquinho
o i am
o i foi lá
em 2009 chamado à oposição que o acusam
de colocar irritada a partida de volta
aqui pergunta do que ele fala como se
tivessem perdido já é conhecida por
fazer
paralelo à
ó
é isso aí larguei o papão tap do trecho
ai ai olha
ae
o élio rusch é fazer compressas o racing
team
i onde meu pé
o mesmo paulo
a boca
é o nosso futebol até que só prega o
nosso tipo a sem chorar mas eu toco na
ii
i
eu acabo galera segunda sessão também
foi muito legal natal foi muito bom
adorei todo negro graças a deus foi tudo
muito louco galera
agora sim finalmente deixando natal e
não em direção à fortaleza e deixando as
cidades que a gente gostou bastante
essa música eu comigo eu vou aqui vou eu
vou que go curte abraçá-la no baile funk
em nada antes o anunciante oms chan foi
pra lá a a coisa tá bonita rocha
hosmany serigado da holanda sodinha i
gostou camarote uva missa da gente aí é
de troy eo bairro da serraria e w
ligeiro e me conectar para o bairro
inteiro tudo costa e lindo aqui tal
curtir o baile as novinhas capela mas
nota 8 ela passou alencar ou depois foi
pra trás
eles comentaram nossa esses caras são
animais
ae eu vou que boa podia abraçar um baile
funk no nada de emocionante no e mission
comprá la a aceitar o quanto estava o
charme das mães se diga não olhamos só
de ida av
gostou camará randy chuva mísseis têm
baguete aí é e citroen e o mairo da
ferrari e da virose gerou be connected
rena para o bairro inteiro todos baixa
eu lido aqui é curtir o baile azul
viagens faltaram mas ontem ela passou a
encarar o tupi depois boiba trajes
também comentaram
nossa eu comigo eu vou que vou eu vou
que vou curtir a peça lá no bairro bom
fim o nada jogos durante o ms chan foi
pra lá há a festa bonita machado
os manos serigado estão rolando só de
galera acabei de chegar em casa graças a
deus eu vou junto em casa e finalmente
aqui no quarto duas horas da tarde
antigo clube fazem de vocês vou dar uma
olhada
olha o pneu
travesseiros
aqui é mais um dólar aqui galera tudo
isso que é prazer de vocês eu adoro
ganhar para fins ela que falou isso que
faz nos presentes em um quarto na minha
casa vou estar presente e é isso que eu
adoro fazer stand up eu adoro fazer show
eu adoro ter esse contato direto com os
fãs porque são dois milhões de pessoas
que estão aqui comigo que estão perto de
mim mas estão do outro lado da tela
então o chão é uma forma de me manter é
uma forma de ter um contato direto com
vocês e séria fico muito feliz com todo
mundo comparece dia 3 e agora de uma
sexta feira eu vou estar em caruaru
a primeira secção de caruaru já esgotou
eu fico feliz pra cá e abriu se e abriu
segunda sessão fechar ó já abriu segunda
sessão lá em caruaru tem ingresso na
loja actual que fica no primeiro piso do
shopping difusora tá e no dia 14 que não
sabe votar em recife no teatro boa vista
tem ingresso na loja petrom que fica no
térreo do shopping riomar tá e para quem
é de olinda e vai receber assist tem
ingresso nem lá no bompreço de bolinha
no estande usa afetado está agora que eu
quero ver em baixo
mas eu quero ver recife eu quero ver
recife toda lá
natal a gente acha que o natal em natal
a gente fez três sessões ela era 36 onde
eu nem sabia que tinha esse tanto de
gente no ataque e assistir gente e eu
também estou muito muito muito feliz que
eu vou votar em fortaleza no dia 28
o jeito é quem não sabe fortaleza acho
que foi um dos primeiros escândalos que
eu fiz na minha vida mas sem dia 28 de
março no centro de eventos do sebrae às
cinco horas da tarde
tá vendendo ingresso na loja norte oeste
e do shopping benfica e do shopping del
paseo del paseo onde eu passo eu passeio
nesse shopping aí que tá aí tem stand up
dia 21 30 na pia 21 em campina grande
tem dia 22 em joão pessoa dia 4 em
mossoró dia 4 de abril em mossoró dia 11
de abril e petróleo no dia 18 em belém
do pará tem muitas muitas muitas outras
cidades você quer saber as próximas
cidades que eu vou onde é que tem reais
para comprar onde é que vai ser o evento
e tal é só clicar no primeiro link que
está aqui na descrição do vídeo o
primeiro primeiro link aqui eu só você
clicar vai aparecer onde acabei de
ingresso em campina grande estava nem
graça em joão pessoa ainda além do pará
em mossoró em fortaleza e recife caruaru
você vai ver tudo tá então é isso aí
galera muito obrigado eu espero que você
tenha curtido passar esses dias comigo é
assistir como é que é mais ou menos
assim o dia de showtec acontece como que
eu vou como eu saio e se você tiver
gostar que vai curtir se deixa aquele
gostei aqui no vídeo aqui tá comenta
aqui em baixo com a cidade você quer que
eu vá se você está no facebook e clique
em curtir também cometem em baixo a
cidade você quer que eu vá se você tem
você tem um amigo que mora em fortaleza
mas com a melhora vai ter show de 28 até
um amigo que mora em campina grande o
campinense na teoria vídeo tal e vão
levar o máximo de gente que puder para
teatro e é isso aí
e valeu e não entre perto